with her gentle gaze and athletic
posture this cow is a beauty she bears
the number 1 9 to 9 but everyone knows
her as Emily her coat gleams and she's
an outstanding producer all reasons why
she was recently ranked among the best
cows in the state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern four years old
she has already had calves twice and
produces 50 litres of milk a day
she's one of 800 high performance cows
on this milk farm Dean and kippers a
Dutchman is the herd manager Emily is
one of his best animals she had a calf
in December and last week I inseminated
her and I hope she's pregnant again 7
new ones on its way
oh my hope so otherwise it can't
continue why not at some point you'll
start giving milk she has two calf again
to keep producing milk me cute what
happens to account that stops keeping
milk yes after the slaughterhouse the
carp dairy farm doesn't slaughter cows
that's done elsewhere female calves
begin producing milk at two years of age
male calves are sold off to sausage
makers all of that makes money but not
as much as this a biogas plant turns
cattle dung into electric energy for the
public power grid without methane the
farmer couldn't pay his bills because
the price of milk has tanked he doesn't
get enough per litre
your boy hmm we need 35 cents to cover
our costs and just break even no profit
there at all at the moment milk hole
sales for 19 to 20 cents so we lose 15
cents per litre
do the math 20,000 liters means a loss
of around 3,000 euros a day without fire
gas dairy farm owner Christian carp
would have given up long ago he has
about 20 employees just to take care of
the cows and take them to the milking
machines he says the whole operation is
species-appropriate because only
contented cows give high quality milk
the stall and milking machines are as
modern as can be this facility is
considered the Mercedes among milking
stands in recent years Christian carp
has invested 2.4 million euros in
equipment wasn't that rather risky the
ups and downs used to average out over
the years but last year they repealed
the system that regulated how much each
farmer could produce there have always
been times where milk prices were down
but prices have been low for a long time
now I'll have to recoup what I'm losing
now in the next year's that'll be very
difficult and who will bear the burden
the cows are driven to the milking stand
three times a day
Emily finds her spot by herself
the machine recognizes her immediately
cow number one nine to nine projected
production this time is 16 liters will
she fulfill expectations this is what
she was bred for to produce twice as
much milk as cow stood 20 years ago now
though if dairy farmers in Germany are
to survive overproduction has to be
drastically reduced Germany needs three
to five percent less production we
already have whole warehouse is full of
powdered milk cutting back by 10 percent
would send a signal and raise the price
fast what's the law of supply and demand
why isn't that done Farms would have to
pull together each farmer secures his
own liquidity by producing as much milk
as possible it's absurd but we have to
produce large volumes to cover our costs
and pay our bills so Emily has to
produce lots too right now she's reached
12 litres now 13 it's like a race she's
meant to finish in 10 minutes the finish
line's in sight
emily is one of the last cows here to
shed the milking pomp and she's reached
her 16 litre quota
afterward she seems a little dazed but
her working day isn't over this evening
in a few hours she'll be milked again